how has drug use or the study of drugs
change you as a human being uh it just
helped me think about other people's
experience right so
how other how we're all connected like
going to northern ireland i don't know
if you know much about the situation
with the troubles and
what those people went through
and so i see people there
northern ireland by the way is all white
and you see those people there suffering
for the same reasons that people in
appalachian are suffering for
neglected by politicians who told them
lies about drugs and not dealing with
the real problems like west virginia for
example uh their water's polluted the
factories have gone away people are
desperate
and they're blaming drugs are you
kidding me
so
the politicians don't have to bring back
the jobs so we don't have to
really make sure they have clean
drinking water things of that nature and
so those people are connected to the
people in northern ireland they're
connected to the people in brownsville
they're connected to the people
in other places in the united states for
the same reason they're connected to the
people in
uh sao paulo uh brazil
same thing people are catching hell for
the same reason in the philippines for
the same reason and that's why i feel so
strongly about this thing because i know
there are people getting paid and their
paycheck is predicated on subjugating
and the suffering of those other people
so when we hear about
the destructive effects of drugs
it's essentially
a scapegoat
for the failures of leaders and
politicians to help alleviate the
suffering of people in those communities
absolutely it's so easy to say
i'm going to rid your community of drugs
i'm going to put more cops on the street
if you want a problem
not to be solved
just give it to the military or the cops
you had a tough childhood growing up in
miami like you said
what memories
memory stands out in particular that was
formative and helping make you the man
you are
uh
that's so hard to you know uh say
um you know my grandmother was really
important
so maybe just her trying to make sure
that i think critically that was i guess
that's the biggest one
so you moved in with her your parents
split
six seven yeah what have you learned
about life from her be self-sufficient
be critical and keep your eyes open and
watch out for the okie doke you know and
that's what
this whole drug thing is about it's the
okie doke people
um
it really boils down to
just simple thing we're all similar in
that we're all just trying to live our
life trying to take care of our kids we
want the best for our kids all of us
but yet
somehow
um we are being we've been made to
believe that we are different in in that
way but fundamentally we're all the same
so when people are
seeking to feel pleasure to feel better
uh why don't we celebrate that
instead
we denigrate people for that i mean if i
feel better i'm more likely to treat you
well
you